c'est une vérité très difficile à
résumer parce qu'elle a été fait de
toutes sortes d'événements inédits
je trouve que nous à confronter au père
et au meilleur de nous-mêmes 2020 c'est
vraiment une année de contrat sont dès
que l'adversité faire en sorte que les
gens se rapprochent cannes solidarité
qui apparaît ça a été une année dans
laquelle on s'enfonçait dans l'inconnu
il fallait rapporter ça en temps réel
travailler avec les impondérables d'un
virus qu'on connaissait très peu au
début aller sur le terrain dans ce
contexte là dans une année comme 2020
c'est beaucoup de gens qui ont des
difficultés mais dans tout ça
que du beau milieu du bon et il ya du
moins pire que ce qu'on craignait aussi
ça a été une année 2020 que j'oublierai
jamais de ma vie
ça a été une année difficile mais
enrichissante à tous points de vue
c'était dur au point de vue
journalistique mais en même temps
c'était stimulant parce qu on couvrait
une histoire qu'on découvrait au fur et
à mesure quand ça a commencé en chine
c'était le début donc on a vu des choses
s'installer petit à petit les gens
portaient des masques ou pénurie de
masques et pressé les prises de
température et des réalités qui ont
rattrapé l'occident quelques semaines
plus tard mais que nous on vivait en
temps réel j'avais l'impression de
débarquer dans dessins de science
fiction et le défi c'était de pouvoir
décrire ce de façon à ce que les gens
comprennent à quel point c'était groupe
j'en discutais avec des collègues on
sait mais mon dieu qu'est ce qu'on est
en train de vivre
on pourra dire qu'on le vécu on le vécu
pour leur apporter
[Musique]
on connaît de new york évidemment comme
étant une ville qui bouge toujours
limité de personnes dans les rues des
lumières partout et là j'entre dans une
ville où tout d'abord de personnes on
voit pas de gens pratiquement dans les
rues et à travers tout ça effectivement
il y avait une solidarité que j'ai
constaté sur place
tous les soirs les gens qui étaient
confinés chez eux sortaient à leur
fenêtre avec des casseroles à la main
pour remercier ce personnel soignant qui
était vraiment à bout de souffle donc
dans toute cette inquiétude cette
incertitude là il y avait quand même une
certaine solidarité de la part des new
york et qui sont des gens qui ont montré
à travers l'histoire qu'ils étaient très
résilient
rappelez-vous l'on remonte au début de
la pandémie en france il y avait pas
assez de gel hydroalcoolique n'avait pas
de masque pour tout le monde y en a mais
pas assez pour les soignants non plus
donc on manquait de tout et l'on
rencontre des gens qui sont timides qui
ont le sourire aux lèvres qui
travaillent fort qui donne quatre heures
par jour
ce monsieur là pharmacien lui s'est dit
je vais faire du gel hydroalcoolique et
assez rapidement il avait les
autorisations pour faire du gel
hydroalcoolique dans la rue
il faisait des galons et des galons et
des galons de gels hydroalcooliques
comme ça donc comprenez lui tout à coup
sa vie à le changer
il agit il réagit et il le fait d'une
manière qu'on n'a probablement jamais vu
à paris en fait d'abord pour dire que la
pandémie a révélé une misère qui étaient
déjà là et ça fait en sorte que des
banques alimentaires ont été prises
d'assaut
en même temps ça révèle oui une volonté
d'entre elles on voit dans les crises
comme ça on voit le pire de l'homme mais
on voit aussi le meilleur c'est aussi en
même temps une crise qui a révélé plus
encore que très souvent le passé et de
ses sujets ont découvert des crises
l'importance
du journalisme aller chercher des faits
aller chercher des témoignages parfois
dans l'adversité ça n'a pas toujours été
facile j'ai eu la chance de rentrer en
russie pour retrouver une russie qui
avait pas changé nécessairement mais qui
est parmi un des pays les plus affectés
au monde on a fait une nuit très
incomplet pour se rendre dans les
régions les plus éloignées pour voir
qu'on avait à faire a dit ville laissée
complètement elles mêmes sont incapables
de surmonter a en toute dignité cette
pandémie dont on connaîtra jamais
vraiment l'ampleur
si l'importance d'être revenu en russie
vous raconter ses histoires lot ça m'a
permis mois comme journaliste de mesurer
l'ampleur de ce qui se passait au moment
où il ya eu cette double explosion sur
le port de beyrouth je ne pouvais pas
imaginer ne pas y aller c'est un pays où
j'ai vécu pendant six ans et de voir qui
a physiquement il reste plus rien de ces
souvenirs là c'est sûr que ça donne un
choc doute plus important et on dit mais
les gabonais vont se remettre
yvon rebâtir ils sont très forts ils ont
survécu à la guerre civile
ils ont tenu bon pendant les conflits
avec le groupe hermitage islamique il
arrive toujours à s'en sortir mais
combien de fonds peut demander à cette
population-là de renaître de ses cendres
parfois c'est difficile d'avoir cette
empathie là de très loin donc nous notre
rôle à chaque fois c'est de donner une
base minimale d'informations pour que
les gens puissent passer au cap de
s'intéresser aussi à ce qui se passe et
c'est vrai qu'avec la pandémie c'est
beaucoup plus simple de le faire ça nous
a tous je pense sur la planète
communément approcher parce qu'il ya cet
élément de base le qu'on partage tous
je pense que la plus value d'être
correspondant à ce moment là surtout
qu'on est là dans le pays depuis
plusieurs années c'est de pouvoir
comparer la situation actuelle à ce qui
devrait être
et ça d'être sur place c'est un
privilège et c'est aussi une grande
responsabilité de pouvoir être capable
de l'expliquer aux canadiens c'est pas
des histoires qui sont évidentes à
courir donc de faire sortir le bien
qu'il y a ou si ça permet à tout le
monde y compris aux journalistes de
souffler un peu et se dire bah écoute
y a pas que du négatif dans tout ça et
on se dit on apporte autre chose que des
mauvaises nouvelles
voici quelqu'un qui respirait et est ce
que cet exemple là va vous inspirez-vous
à faire quelque chose chez vous qui sera
peut-être différent mais qui serait
quand même positif aussi je pense que la
personne qu'on a rencontré qu'on
interviews et qui m'a le plus touché
c'est ginette kolinka qui est une
survivante des camps dash-8 avec qui on
est retourné dans les camps c'est une
femme extraordinaire parce qu'elle a une
résilience mais c'est une force de la
nature aussi c'est vraiment un privilège
inouï ton et journaliste de montrer
qu'il ya des solutions aux problèmes
qu'on rencontre tous moi c'est john
reportage que je préfère faire parce que
j'aime montrer le meilleur de l'humain
et je trouve ça donne tout le sens aussi
à nos travail tend à l'occasion de
couvrir ça aussi c'est là où la
commission prend tout son sens
de la chance d'aller passer une semaine
à saint pétersbourg voir les plus grands
ballets du monde ce qui est
extraordinaire et de les voir ouvrir
pendant la coved pour remonter le moral
de la population
c'est une belle façon de finir l'année
puis de montrer que la vie continue
[Musique]